pasada la medianoche en este Valle del
centro de Grecia sucedió lo impensable
un tren interurbano de pasajeros que
viajaba desde Atenas a salónica chocó
con un tren de mercancías a gran
velocidad de los cerca de 350 pasajeros
decenas murieron y resultaron heridos
oímos un gran estruendo Fueron 10
segundos de Pesadilla estuvimos dando
vueltas en el vagón hasta que caímos de
costado Entonces cundió el pánico cables
fuego el fuego fue inmediato nos
estábamos quemando ahora a los equipos
de rescate siguen buscando
supervivientes y cuerpos entre los
escombros por el momento se desconocen
las causas del accidente pero las
autoridades han prometido investigar a
fondo y determinar Por qué los dos
trenes estaban en la misma vía tragedia
tras la que el ministro de transporte ha
anunciado su renuncia como muestra de
respeto hacia los fallecidos
investigaremos con total severidad con
total transparencia las razones de este
trágico incidente me gustaría que todo
el mundo mostrara calma y se centrara en
lo que he dicho haremos todo lo posible
para investigar las razones y no dejar
nada por fuera
Este es el accidente de tren a más
mortífero que recuerda el país del sur
de Europa algo que ha puesto en relieve
el deterioro del sector ferroviario en
el país en lo que los expertos han
denominado como un accidente que no se
corresponde con el siglo XXI